very generic and worse not only do we
see buildings that were very generic so
not only was the reading room looked
like the copy room looked like the
magazine area but it meant that whatever
issue was troubling the library at that
moment was starting to engulf every
other activity that was happening in it
and in this case what was getting
engulfed for these social
responsibilities by the expansion of the
book and so we proposed what's at the
lower diagram very dumb approach simply
compartmentalized put those things whose
evolution we could predict and I don't
mean that we could say what it'll
actually happen in the future but we
have some certainty of the spectrum of
what it would happen in the future put
those in boxes designed specifically for
it and put the things that we can't
predict on their rooftops so that was
the core idea now we had to convince the
library that social roles was equally
important to media in order to get them
to accept this what you're seeing here
is actually their program on the Left
that's as it was given to us in all of
its clarity and glory our first
operation was to read I jest it or back
to them show it to them and say you know
what we haven't touched it but only
one-third of your own program is
dedicated to median books two thirds of
it is all
dedicated that's the white band below
the thing you say isn't important is
already dedicated to social functions so
once we had presented that back to them
they agreed that this sort of core
concept could work we got the right to
go back to first principles that's the
third diagram we recombined everything
and then we started making new decisions
which is seeing on the right is the
design of the library specifically in
terms of square footage on the left of
that diagram here you'll see a series of
five platforms sort of combs collective
programs and on the right of the more
indeterminate spaces things like Reading
Room's whose evolution in 20 30 or 40
years we can't predict so that literally
was the design of the building they
signed it in to the chagrin we came back
a week later and we friends because I
did them this okay and as you can see it
is literally the diagram on the right
okay we just sized
really I mean that literally the things
in there on the left-hand side of the
diagram was those are the boxes we sized
them into five compartments are super
efficient we had a very low budget to
work with we pushed them around on the
site to make very literal contextual
relationships the reading room should be
able to see the water the main entrance
should have a public plaza in front of
it to abide by the zoning code and so
forth so you see the five platforms
those are the boxes within each one a
very discrete thing is happening the
area in between is sort of an urban
continuum these things that we can't
predict the revolution to the same
degree to give you some sense of the
power of this idea the biggest bought
block is what we call the book spiral is
literally built in a very inexpensive
way it is a parking garage for books it
just so happens to be on the sixth
through tenth floor of the building but
that is not necessarily an expensive
approach and it allows us to organize
the entire Dewey Decimal System on one
continuous run no matter how it grows or
contracts within the building it will
always have its clarity to end the sort
of Trail of Tears that we've all
experienced in public letters
and so this is the final operation which
is to take these blocks as that were all
pushed off kilter and to hold onto them
with a skin that skin serves double duty
again for economics one it is the
lateral stability for the entire
building it's a structural element and
but it's dimensions are designed not
only for structure but also for holding
on every piece of glass the glass was
then I'll see use the word impregnate if
it had a layer of metal that was called
stretched metal that metal acts as a
micro louver so from the exterior the
building the Sun sees it is totally
opaque but from the interior it's
entirely transparent so now I'm going to
take you on a tour of the building let's
see if I can find it
for anyone who is uh gets motion
sickness I apologize so this is the
building and I think what's important is
when we first unveiled the building the
public thought saw it as being totally
about our whim and ego and it was
defended believe it or not by the
librarians they said look we don't know
what it is but we know it's everything
that we need it to be based on the
observations that we've done about the
program this is going into one of the
entries so it's an unusual building for
a public library obviously so now we're
going into what we call the reading room
as our living room this is actually a
program that we invented with the
library it was recognizing that public
libraries are the last vestige of public
free space there are plenty of shopping
malls that allow you to get out of the
rain and in downtown Seattle but there
are not so many free places that allows
you to get out of the rain
so this was an unprivileged anything
including etl play chess and so forth
now we're moving up into what we call
the mixing chamber that was the main
sort of technology area in the building
if it tell me if I'm going too fast for
you
and now up
this is actually the place that we put
into the building so I could propose to
my wife right there she said yes
I'm running out of time so I'm actually
going to stop I can show this to you
later but this if I can very quickly get
into the book spiral because I think
it's as I said the most this is the main
reading room the most unique part of the
building you dizzy yeah okay so here
this is the book spiral
so it's variant a certain indiscernible
but it's actually a continuous stair
stepping it allows you to on one city
block go up one full floor so that it's
on a continuum okay now I'm going to go
back and certainly hit a second project
if you go very very quickly through this
and this is this Dallas theater it was
an unusual client for us because they
came to us and they said we need you to
do a new building we've been working in
a temporary space for thirty years but
because of that temporary space we'd
become an infamous theater company
theater is really focused in New York
Chicago and Seattle with the exception
of the Dallas Theater Company and the
very fact that they worked in a
provisional space meant that for Beckett
they could blow out a wall they could do
Cherry Orchard and blow a hole through
the floor and so forth so it was a very
daunting task for us to do a brand new
building that could keep the the sort of
pristine building but keep this kind of
experimental nature the second is they
were what we call a multi form theater
they do different kinds of performances
in repertory so they in the morning will
do something in arena then they'll do
something and proscenium and so forth
and so they needed to be able to quickly
transform between different theater
organizations and for operational budget
reasons this actually no longer happens
and pretty much any multi form theater
in the United States so we needed to
figure out a way to overcome that so our
thought was to literally put the theater
on its head to take those things that
are previously defined as front of house
and back of house and stack them above
house and below house and to create so
what we started to call a theater
machine we invest the money in the
operation of the building it's almost as
though the building could be placed
anywhere wherever you place it the area
underneath it is charged for theatrical
performances and it allowed us to go
back to first principles and redefine
flight our acoustic enclosure light
enclosure and so forth and out of the
push of a button that allows the
artistic director to move between
proscenium thrust and in fact arena and
Traverse and flat floor in a very quick
defense for the Transfiguration so in
fact we can go using operational budget
we can sari capital costs we can
actually achieve what was not no longer
achievable and operational cost and that
means that the artistic director now has
a pallet that he or she can
choose from between a series of forms in
a series of processions because that
enclosure around the theater that is
normally trapped with front of house and
back of house spaces has been liberated
so an artistic director has the ability
to show have a performance that enters
into vogner aryan procession shows the
first act and thrusts the intermission
in a Greek procession second act in
arena and so forth so I'm going to show
you what what this actually means this
is the theater up close any portion
around the theater actually can be open
discreetly the light enclosure can be
lifted separate so you can cuckoo stick
enclosure so you can do Beckett with
Dallas as the backdrop fortunes can be
open so you can now actually have
motorcycles drive directly into the
performance or you can even just have an
open air performance or for
intermissions the balcony is all moved
goes between those configurations but
they also disappear the proscenium line
can also disappear you can bring
enormous objects in so in fact there the
Dallas Theater Company the first show
will be played by Charles Lindbergh and
they'll want to bring in real aircraft
and then it also provides them in the
offseason the ability to actually rent
out this space for entirely different
things this is it at night oh sorry
from a distance open up entire portions
for different kinds of events and at
night again
remove the light enclosure keep the
acoustic enclosure this is a monster
truck show I'm going to show now the
last project this also is an unusual
client they inverted the whole idea of
development they came to us and they
said unlike normal developers and they
said we want to start out by providing a
Contemporary Art Museum in Louisville
that's our main goal and so instead of
being a developer that sees an
opportunity to make money they saw a
ability to be a catalyst in their
downtown and the fact that they wanted
to support the Contemporary Art Museum
actually built the pro forma so they
worked in Reverse and that Performa led
us to a mixed-use building that was very
large in order to support their
aspirations of the art but it also
opened up opportunities for the art
itself to collaborate interact with
commercial spaces that actually artists
more and more
to work within and it also charged us
with thinking about how to have
something that was both a single
building and a credible sort of sub
buildings so I'm gonna this is
Louisville's skyline and I'm going to
take you through the various constraints
that led to the project first the
physical constraints we actually had to
operate on three discrete sites all of
them well well smaller than the size of
the building we had operate next to the
new Muhammad Ali's Center and respected
we had to operate within the hundred
year flood plain now this area floods
three to four times a year and there's a
levee behind our site similar to the
ones that broke in New Orleans have to
operate in the high into the i-64
corridor a street that cuts through the
middle of these separate sites so these
were starting to build a sort of
nightmare of constraints in a bathtub
underneath the bathtub are the city's
main power lines and there was a
pedestrian corridor that they wanted to
add that would link a series of cultural
buildings and a view corridor because
this is the historic district that they
didn't want to obstruct with the new
building and now we're going to add 1.1
million square feet and if we did the
traditional thing that 1.1 million
square feet these are the different
programs traditional thing would be to
identify the public elements place them
on sites and now we'd have a really
terrible situation a public thing in the
middle of a bathtub that floods and then
we would size all the other elements the
different commercial elements Hotel
luxury housing office and so forth and
dump it on top and we would create
something that was unveiled the Time
Warner building so our strategy was very
simple just lift the entire block flip
some the elements over reposition them
so they have appropriate views and
relationships to downtown and make
circulation connections and reroute the
road so that's the basic concept now I'm
going to show you what it leads to okay
seems very formal willful gesture that
something derive entirely out of the
constraints and again when we unveiled
it there was sort of nervousness that
this was about an architect making a
statement not an architect was
attempting to solve a series of problems
now within that Center zone as I said we
have the ability to mix a series of
things so here you can see that these
are the this sort of an x-ray that the
towers a totally developer driven they
told us that dimensions the sizes and so
forth and we focused on taking all the
public components the lobbies the bars
everything that the different component
of different commercial elements would
have and combined it in the center in
this sort of subway map in the transfer
zone that it would also include the
Contemporary Art Museum that creates a
situation like this we have artists who
can operate within an art space that
also has an amazing view on the 22nd
floor but it also has proximity that the
curator can either open or close it
allows people on exercise bicycles to be
seen or to see the art and so forth it
also means if an artist wants to invade
something like a swimming pool they can
begin to do the exhibition in the
swimming pool
so not forced to always work within the
confines of a contemporary gallery space
so how to build this it's very simple
it's a chair so we begin by building the
cores as we're building the cores we
build the Contemporary Art Museum at
grade that allows us to have incredible
efficiency and cost efficiency this is
not a high budget building at the moment
the course gets a mid-level we finished
the art museum we put all the mechanical
equipment in it and then we jack it up
into the air this is how they build
really large aircraft hangars for
instance the ones that they did for the
a380 finish the course finish the meat
you get something that looks like this I
only have about 30 seconds so I want to
start an animation and we'll conclude
with that
first asked me to add the theater is
under construction and this project will
start construction in about a year and
finish in 2010
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance or
held no value there is a place where
artistic vision is protected where
inspired design ideas live on to become
ultimate driving machines